déjà elle se situe à une cinquantaine de
kilomètres au sud de la ville du même
nom et elle a été occupée par les Russes
dès le début de l'intervention dès le
début de la guerre en Ukraine elle était
toujours donc elle était sous contrôle
de la Russie mais opérer par
ennergoatome une agence d'État
ukrainienne qui était sous les ordres et
qui sont toujours sous les ordres de la
Russie des facto alors pendant des mois
l'Ukraine a refusé elle-même de son côté
que des observateurs internationaux
viennent sur le site parce que pour eux
c'était admettre d'une certaine manière
que cette centrale était bien sous
contrôle russe et donc il ne il
n'acceptait pas cette intervention de
ces observateurs internationaux et puis
il y a eu des nouvelles frappes répétées
depuis le 6 août dernier qui ont
inquiété la communauté internationale et
l'Ukraine a changé de braquet à accepter
à même demander à ce que des
observateurs de la IEA interviennent sur
cette sur le site de cette centrale pour
à tout le moins pouvoir constater les
dommages sur cette centrale nucléaire
qui est la plus puissante de un petit
fournit 20% d'électricité à l'Ukraine et
qui a si réacteurs donc c'est une
centrale nucléaire très importante le
risque de catastrophe et nucléaire est
évidemment
présent avec toutes ces frappes dont
s'accusent respectivement la Russie et
l'Ukraine depuis plusieurs semaines
maintenant et bien aujourd'hui déjà avec
l'appel de entrée manuel Macron et
Vladimir Poutine mais également avec la
prise de parole d'un diplomate russe
Mireille ou lianov qui disait donc ils
ont changé d'avis puisqu'il disait
aujourd'hui nous discutons actuellement
avec la IEA de ce problème et il disait
je sais que je parle quasiment
quotidiennement avec Raphaël grossir
Rafael grossi c'est le directeur général
de l'UEA et là on rentre un petit peu
dans le détail puisque ils ont commencé
à parler vraiment de logistiques ils ont
commencé à discuter du nombre
d'inspecteurs qui seraient autorisés à
venir quelle route ils allaient
emprunter combien de temps ils allaient
rester et enfin quelle tâche vous allez
mener on rappelle que l'OTAN aussi bien
que Washington mais aussi le secrétaire
général de l'ONU demande la venue de ses
observateurs en Tonio guteres qui
réclamait la démilitarisation de cette
zone Antonio gouterres qui est à audessa
aujourd'hui un le grand port d'où
partent à nouveau les navires chargés de
céréales ukrainiennes depuis un mois
grâce à l'accord conclu avec la Russie
reste maintenant à accélérer sa mise en
œuvre Mélina
oui tout à fait en tenue qui déambulait
dans les rues d'adier ça dans le blast
du même nom à ça qui a trois grands
ports dont celui de la ville d'odessad
donc mais aussi de tcharne Morse d'où
partent des navires depuis le 1er août
donc l'accord a été signé le 22 juillet
sa visite intervient quasiment 4
semaines après la signature de l'accord
à Istanbul sous l'égide de l'ONU et
aussi de la Turquie donc Anthony
gouttière est-ce qu'il voulait voir un
petit peu comment ça se passe de manière
logistique et pragmatique comment ces
navires marchands étaient chargés de ses
grains on rappelle que depuis le début
de l'intervention depuis le début de la
guerre il y a plus de 20 millions de
tonnes de céréales qui sont encore
stockées dans les ports d'Odessa et aux
alentours dans des silos cela a créé une
crise alimentaire mondiale le cours du
blé s'est envolé Antonio guteresque qui
disait hier lors d'une réunion
tripartite avec vous l'audimères
zenenski mais également Ratchet tape
douane qu'il se satisfaisait de cet
accord que c'était une victoire pour je
cite la diplomatie et le multi
latéralisme mais qui s'inquiétait un
petit peu de la cadence il demandait à
ce que tout cela puisse s'accélérer et
il a regretté un petit peu cet
après-midi de voir les ports un peu
vides de voir ces navires qui attendent
désespérément d'être chargé il y a une
nouvelle récolte dans les prochaines
semaines qui va venir ajouter 20 à 25
millions de tonnes supplémentaires de
céréales donc pour pouvoir écouler tout
ces stocks et bien il va falloir
augmenter la cadence il faudrait dans
l'idéal qu'au moins 5 millions de tonnes
de céréales partent par mois tout comme
avant guerre c'est-à-dire environ 100
navires marchand et donc Anthony
gouterraz qui disait quand même se
satisfaire d'une chose c'est que depuis
la signature de cet accord le cours du
blé qui avait donc grimpé a chuté de 8%
et cet historique depuis 2008 merci
Mélina Huet avec nous en direct de Kiev
le Pentagone Ann